i got uh ann on the line anne how are
you
hi chris hi anthony thank you for taking
my call yes ma'am how can we help you
today
um i'm finding myself uh you know
not disciplining myself enough to try to
pay off my
uh home my home okay i'm on a fixed
income
a disability retirement income and
um i'm only the only debt that i have
is my mortgage and but i'm kind of
stingy with letting
extra money go so i'm just trying to get
some guidance on how i can
do that okay well hold on a minute uh
what what do you mean you're kind of
stingy what do you mean
well i i i know i have enough to
send you know to extra to pay on my
mortgage to get
me so i don't get it down but
that's the stinky part i just i don't i
i find myself saying well i don't want
to spend this much what if something
happens
right so and you know you know what your
answer is i just said why don't you send
in extra on the mortgage
the straight up answer is because you
don't want to um
am i telling the truth yeah that's sure
right
and so what we got to do ao was just
talking about
digging in and finding the why
so why why should you pay extra on the
mortgage
uh because i want to get this paid off
and why do you want it paid off
to me i guess be debt-free why you want
to be that free
i don't have to really worry about
worry about a lot of things that's right
there you go you see and so
looking at this now what you can do is
be real with yourself
and now you can start to figure out okay
what's the plan now yeah
so tell me this how much income do you
have coming in
each month um
about 35.70 okay and how much is your
mortgage payment
uh 11 30. and how much do you owe on the
house
about 155. and listen to me anne
because i tend to talk fast what else do
you owe on
nothing okay now people get amnesia on
me and sometimes so let me just double
check
you gotta eat credit cards i have one
how much is on it all the only thing i
owe is eight dollars
on it it is that's because it's a it's
it's one of those ones where they have a
maintenance fee every month so it's
eight dollars that pops on there
okay so we're gonna close that out and
get rid of that all right got any car
loans
no all right now what i'm saying is
looking at it do you have an emergency
fund in place
um i'm gonna have savings how much do
you have in savings
about 12 000. okay
so you got an emergency fund we got to
see for you you need the structure
yeah did you do this alone all right and
listen to me
my i got one here on top of this head
tell me this do you have a 15-year
mortgage or did you do a 30-year
30. it's a 30-year all right what's your
interest rate on this mortgage
okay so it's a conventional so actually
the loan it
allowed me to finance the 20 and
uh so the 20 percent is 4.75
and the 80 uh part is
2.24 you did an 80 20. they gave you a
heloc didn't they
a home equity line of credit is
and so they gave you a big old credit
card attached to your house is what that
is
oh okay so okay all right here's the
reality
for you you are sitting at a point
you've got 3 570
coming in a month you've got an
incredible opportunity to really zero in
and get focused
and i say that because you know the 80
loans at 2 point
i think you said 2.29 but if you zero in
and get intentional
quote pay that little eight dollars on
that little dirty credit card off today
okay the little maintenance charge shut
it down shut it down get it out of your
life
but turn your attention over to this 20
now and get this thing serious and get
it paid off
uh you can do this is anybody else in
your family ann
ever owned their home free and clear
i know everyone's just financed did you
hear that yeah
you want you want you want to do
something new for your family tree
yeah you really you would you would you
love to hold them grand babies on your
lap one day and talk to them about how
you paid off that house
how that deed is over there in a frame
and you can go over and grab it
yeah yeah and and i think hopefully you
heard hogan earlier
you know when i'm listening to you i
don't really feel
the depth in your motivation
and i really want you to spend this
weekend really just asking yourself
what's my why
it sounds like you you want to be safe
and i totally understand it
i don't need to know your age but by the
way you're sounding it sounds like you
would rather be
safe than be aggressive but i think
that's okay but at the same time if
you're making that kind of money
and you can be a little bit more
aggressive and still be safe
and go ahead and create some wealth for
your family so what i
really pray that you you do from this
phone call is hear hogan hear
hear me um spend this weekend just
digging in why why why why do i want
financial freedom why do i want
financial peace
and when you get that deep enough why
your motivation
is going to be so good to where i think
you may even start leaning more on the
aggressive side
than safe side yeah ao's being nice i'm
being coach hogan
and get fired up let's get intentional
and start changing your family tree
be that story that your great grandkids
get to talk about because you got
focused and not finished young lady
you can do this and we're here to help
this is
the ramsay show